There is a shortage of people who have a
technology background and it's really
becoming a business problem.
And it's one of the number of things.
Number one,
things that ceos complain about,
two members of Congress when I see them,
is that it's difficult to get visas.
So you might have someone from Pakistan
who has a master's in computer science,
uh,
wants to come to United States and get a
job.
I would argue that that's credibly
beneficial for our economy.
And if he doesn't come here and millions
like that,
then what companies will do is end up
employing people in other countries,
which is okay from my selfish interest,
but not as good for the country overall.
And so the,
as you know,
there's an enormous outsource community
in India with hundreds of thousands of
people,
which is fantastic for India.
And I'm supportive of that.
But putting on my us hat,
I'd love to have many of those people in
the United States,
uh,
working for companies,
creating jobs and then at some point
spinning off and starting new companies.
So anything we can do that it is more
training and,
uh,
and more visas for qualified people,
I think is great for this country.